Yeah.
There was a young artist who dropped out of school at the age of 16 his mother
patiently urged him to get a job or learn a trade,
but to him,
this idea of daily work in submitting to authority was revolting.
His father had passed away and his mother could not convince him to do what she
told.
He would spend his time wandering around his own city,
visiting museums,
attending the opera and sitting by the river dreaming of becoming a great
artist.
He had a very fantastical view of the world.
He would borrow a large number of books from the library on history and Nordic
mythology and let his mind get lost in his crazy imaginings of the world.
At the age of 17 he took his first trip to Vienna,
one of the most important centers of art,
music and old world European culture.
He was in thrall by the city's magnificent architecture here.
He dove deeply into his art.
He could draw detailed pictures from the memory of a building.
He had only seen once a very rare skill to have,
but when he returned home he had little motivation to do well in school.
After dropping out,
he put all this hope into achieving greatness as an artist.
At the age of 18 he had rolled in the Vienna Academy of Fine Arts.
He had taken all his money and planned to live and study in Vienna.
He had taken a huge risk and stick his whole life on his belief in himself as an
artist.
After taking the two day entrance exam,
he felt confident,
assured that he was going to get in,
but failure struck him like lightening.
His drawings were judged as unsatisfactory and he was told he had a lack of
artistic talent with a notable lack of appreciation for the human form.
Shaken,
heartbroken and rejected.
He left Vienna and returned home planning to take the entrance exam next year,
but things didn't quite go to plan for him.
The next year he failed the exam again and his beloved mother died after a long
battle with cancer.
It wasn't long before he ran out of money and was forced to live in homeless
shelters and mince hostels.
He was a broken man,
rejected and told he wasn't good enough that his dreams would never come true
with not much left to turn to.
He enlisted in the army in war.
He was able to get in glory.
He never achieved through his art.
He described war as the greatest of all experiences and he was praised by his
commanders for his bravery after the war had ended and with no other real skills
or education.
He remained in the military where they gave him an assignment to infiltrate the
DAP or German Workers Party.
He quickly gained influence in the group and especially gay notoriety for his
public speaking skills.
He proceeded to attract a larger and larger crowds to the parties events.
He soon got the DAP to change its name to the national German Workers Party or
you will probably know a better as the Nazi party.
He even designed the parties new banner and I think we all know where the story
goes from here.
Most of us have two.
The life we live and the unlived life within us between the two stands
resistance,
that destructive force inside human nature that arises whenever we consider a
tough long term course of action that might actually do something that's good
for once.
We've all felt it.
If you've ever tried to quit a habit or addiction,
ever tried to start any creative or entrepreneurial venture or ever tried to
take up any act of moral,
political or ethical courage,
you have felt resistance.
Resistance can defeat any one of us and for Hitler it was literally easier to
start world war two than it was to face a blank square of canvas.
Everyday resistance beat him like it beats most the warrior and the artist live
by the same code each day.
The battle must be fought anew.
The artist must prepare his mind for the long haul.
He knows if he caves to resistance,
he will be twice as likely to cave tomorrow.
The artist's gives resistance to utmost respect.
He knows it can defeat him on any given day.
Just as the need for a drink can overcome an alcoholic.
All we can do is sit down and do the work day after day.
When you look up at the clock hours later,
you will know I've put in my time and I hit it with all that I have,
and that is all that counts this day.
I have overcome resistance.